did you know that bananas are actually
radioactive that's right the breakfast
that you've been enjoying all these
years image radiation how is that soap
so bananas have this interesting
naturally occurring isotope called
potassium 40 which gives it its
radioactive properties and hence it
emits radiation
now bananas are one of the most reactive
foods that you can eat but before you
start to worry
there is nothing to be scared about
because the level of radiation that you
might be exposed to while consuming a
banana is very very very very less and
it's absolutely not harmful in fact in a
lot of ways beneficial to eat banana
okay so can you name me in the comment
section below any other reductive foods
that you can think of and don't forget
to subscribe to don't memorize and hit
the Bell icon